tv series and topics list on the upper
right side of the page
up next jefferson morley recounts the
first race riot in washington dc which
took place in august of 1835 and the two
subsequent criminal trials that were
tried by dc's district attorney francis
scott key
mr key who authored the star-spangled
banner defended slavery in his
prosecution and sought capital
punishment only to be thwarted by the
alleged victim anna thornton whose late
husband william thornton designed the
u.s capitol
this is just over 50 minutes
you ethan for that nice introduction um
and thanks to majors and quinn for
hosting this event um i had suggested
this uh to ethan back in the winter and
uh they were never anything less than
enthusiastic about having me so i was
this was my always my destination when i
came to a minneapolis bookstore and i'm
very glad i landed here
um
i want to tell you a little bit about
the book i'm going to read a little bit
about the book um
it's nice to be here and see so many old
familiar faces um
you know whenever i come back to
minneapolis i i have this feeling of
what a special place marshall you was
and i think there's probably a few
people here who will at least remember
the place uh if not agree with me um
uh and uh so it's always nice to be to
be back with old friends i i'll really
date myself here i even i even attended
an advanced placement class at the old
west high school
which was right down here on hennepin
and you have to be really old to
remember when west high school was there
so
[Laughter]
um you know people have asked me a lot
they said well you know what why did you
write this book it's so uh so long ago
and and so obscure and i usually say
because it's just a great story it's
just a story of what happened the events
themselves are so amazing and you as a
writer as a fiction writer i would never
i would never dare to to make them up
the kind of plot twist that this book
has and when i realized that they had
all happened i thought that was that was
really terrific and so for a long time
when people said why'd you write this
book i said because it was such a great
story but as i got into the book i
realized it was there was actually more
to it than that and uh the book actually
had an even more profound message and
that was that
this book takes place between the
revolutionary war period the founding
you know the founding of the country in
the late 18th century and the civil war
which are the two great periods in
american history that get written a lot
by about historians the american
revolution in the civil war period in
between
uh you know kind of ignored and
what i realized as i was writing this
book is pretty much everything you know
about that period and everything that
you've been taught about that period
is flat wrong is completely wrong
and uh and so i realized that part of
the of this book is to is
is to tell people that that that
everything you thought you understood
about this time is completely wrong so
if you think of
washington in 1835 25 years before the
civil war um you know what would you
think you would think well you know
slavery was well entrenched you know the
black people were miserable
uh the whites were kind of cruel and
indifferent
and that's actually
not true at all in washington um in
washington washington had about 30 000
people then as a city 12 000 of them
were black the majority of the black
people in washington actually in 1830
were free were not slaves
out of the 12 000 black people slightly
more than half
were free
some were prosperous and and and others
were getting there fast there was a man
named lynch wormley who owned a big
livery stable um about a couple two
blocks from the white house um and he
served horses to the to the city's taxi
trade he was a free black man from
madagascar
there were a couple of there were two
brothers thomas and
thomas and isaac carey they owned a
couple of barber shops on pennsylvania
avenue
they came from a free black family in
virginia that had been free for
generations in fact one of those black
families that owned slaves themselves
the carrie brothers also while they were
cutting hair would also sell
anti-slavery publications on the sly on
the side um and uh and and the hero of
the book beverly snow was uh ran the
city's finest restaurant called the
epicurean eating house uh he's really
the hero of the book i kind of think of
him as a barack obama slightly ahead of
his time a very clever intelligent
mixed-race man who kind of comes out of
nowhere to conquer and charm washington
uh serve the washington elite what they
want
only to face a tremendous backlash and i
think if you read the book you'll see
some parallels to our own time there but
anyway the point is that uh uh in in in
this book far from slavery being uh
dominant uh in washington dc and and an
all-oppressive uh force slavery is
actually receding and the forces of
liberty are growing and that's really
part of what this book is about
um a second thing you probably think is
you probably think the civil war began
in
oh you know april 1861 with the with the
with the with with the with the fight
with the gunfire at fort sumter uh
that's when the shooting of the civil
war began but part of the argument of
this book is that the civil war actually
began 30 years before that um it is in
this period in the early 1800s that the
anti-slavery movement first comes to
washington and the direct ideological
conflict that leads to the civil war the
conflict between the people who are for
slavery and the conflict and the people
who are against it it actually starts in
this time in washington uh that's not
something that uh you get taught in the
history books but you'll see from this
story that that is actually the case and
that that's what happened um so uh it's
this band of people the carrie brothers
um uh lynch wormley beverly snow uh uh
who actually are the ones who really
start the fight against slavery that
leads to the civil war and the great
expansion of american freedom that that
brought
um
uh
they had a um
this little group of of of black
entrepreneurs had a white friend a man
named ben lundy he was an itinerant
editor
traveled around the country kind of like
a familiar fate
for me
and
he had an anti-slavery newspaper called
the genius of universal emancipation and
he would travel around and
most of the newspapers of the day the
msm of the day really avoided the
slavery issue and and didn't really i
mean they'd report on the politics of it
but they didn't really want to get into
it ben lundy went around the country and
he reported you know there was a you
know there was a killing this man was
beat here's how these slaves escaped
here's you know here's how the churches
have caved in i mean he really did real
investigative reporting about slavery
he's quite unprecedented at the time and
as
anti-slavery sentiment is as this
movement starts to grow in washington he
has enough money to hire a new assistant
and he hires a promising young man from
boston named william lloyd garrison and
he teaches william lloyd garrison how to
be a journalist and how to report about
slavery and in a great irony benjamin
lundy would go on to die in obscurity
and william lloyd garrison would go on
to become the most famous abolitionist
editor and one of the most influential
american journalists of the 19th century
he's a character in this book too
another thing you probably think is you
probably think well the you know the
only important thing that francis scott
key did in his life was write the lyrics
to the star spangled banner uh wrong
again
after francis scott key wrote the lyrics
to the swear spangle banner in 1814 he
went on to a long and very interesting
career in politics which is completely
unknown to most people um
francis scott key really was kind of a
modern washington character um after he
became famous in 1814 for writing the
star spangled banner he did what people
in washington usually do he parlayed his
fame into a lucrative law practice
and then he parlayed his lucrative law
practice into political connections and
then he parlayed his political
connections into a job
and that was the culmination of of
francis scott key's political career in
1833 when he was appointed to be the
district attorney for the city of
washington
and what he did in that time
was uh i wouldn't say it was as
significant as writing the star spangled
banner which was obviously an enduring
feat but it was very important
unknown uh an unknown fact about francis
scott key is that his best friend and
brother-in-law was a man named roger
tawny
uh and roger tawny was like key very
politically ambitious and
um uh
with keys help ascended two jobs in the
in the administration of andrew jackson
first uh
key helped tawny become the us attorney
general uh then the secretary of the
treasury and then in 1836 the chief
justice of the supreme court roger
tawney went on to write the dred scott
decision in 1857
which effectively legalized slavery and
hastened the coming of the civil war so
he and tawny were inseparable political
figures in in this period and
influential and important in a way that
has been um totally forgotten in
washington there's a
there's a key bridge which crosses the
potomac river and right by where it is
is a a park where he used used to live
his house and and in the park there's
lots of exhibits that are devoted to him
and there's one that says
he was active in anti-slavery causes
and this is flat wrong it's completely
wrong it's it uh it would be much more
accurate to say that key was active in
suppressing anti-slavery causes
part of the point of this book is that
to remind people of all the things that
we really um don't want to remember
about our own history so this is a book
also a book about the real francis scott
key
but i don't want to give the wrong
impression um
this book is not a polemical book it's
not how to score points it's mostly out
to tell this amazing story of the events
of washington in 1835 and 1836 which
began
on the night of august 4th
1835 177 years ago
when
a uh
a young man a servant a 19 year old
african-american uh man stumbles into
the bedroom of his mistress of the woman
who owns him anna maria thornton in the
middle of the night carrying an axe
and uh mrs thornton is sleeping in in
the room with
her servant
who is arthur's mother the mother of the
boy who has just stumbled into the room
so the two women wake up
scream uh arthur's mother shoots him out
out the door uh
slams the door arthur's outside yelling
and shouting that he wants to be free
that he's going to be free the neighbors
gather
and arthur runs away and the word begins
to spread mrs thornton has been attacked
in her bedroom
by a slave with an axe this this report
comes at a very uh a very tense time in
washington this burgeoning anti-slavery
movement is distributing anti-slavery
publications uh
to everybody in town
for the first time uh the anti-slavery
movement is really impressing upon
people the reality of slavery with these
kind of written reports very detailed
about what is really involved in the
brutality of slavery and so among among
the the blacks and the abolitionist
whites this is this is overdue but among
a lot of whites they fear that this is
the first shot in a slave rebellion and
that that arthur that arthur was part of
a slave rebellion in attacking mrs
thornton and
so when arthur turns himself in a few
days later and says i have no memory of
what happened
he's whisked off to jail and a mob
converges on the jail in in downtown
washington in judiciary square um and
tries to
seeking to lynch arthur demanding that
he'd be turned over so that he can be
hung on the spot
key is francis scott key comes to the
defense of the jail and is trying to
hold back the crowd he's about to get
overrun
when fortunately the secretary of the
navy calls in
the federal troops the marines from the
navy yard on the other side of
washington the troops marched down
pennsylvania avenue
surround the jail and push the crowd
back and protect the jail so that arthur
will not be lynched
so
order is only temporarily restored
though because the mob frustrated by the
fact that they cannot put get their
hands on arthur bowen decide to turn
their fury on every other free black
person in town
and so uh the mobs begin to split up and
attack
the people any black people have
property the black churches the black
schools the black [ __ ] houses any place
where black people gathered the mobs
were going to destroy it including first
and foremost
beverly snow's restaurant which is a
symbol the symbol in washington of black
success the restaurant's right in the
heart of town at the corner of sixth and
pennsylvania it's frequented by
politicians senators congressmen
the finest of high society beverly snow
is a well-known and respected character
and
the mob in its fear of this anti-slavery
movement and this fear of a slave
insurrection and its fear of black
success
attacks snow um snow had friends he knew
there was trouble coming and he uh
manages to escape and get away
but the mob trashes his restaurant poor
drinks all his liquor pours it all out
and then goes on this rampage and
destroys the city
and it's quite a shocking event
it's totally been totally forgotten in
the history of washington uh when i
asked people about this one reason i
decided to write the book was i asked
people if they'd ever heard of the riot
of 1835 in washington and i never met
anybody who had
completely forgotten but
when you read the newspapers of the day
you realize what a shocking event it was
it was the worst thing that had happened
in washington
since the british had invaded 20 years
before in 1814 and they came in and
destroyed the white house and the
library of congress and all that well
this was comparable damage but it had
not been inflicted by a foreign army it
had been inflicted by americans
themselves and there was a lot of shame
and remorse about how could this happen
a lot of recriminations and so
francis scott key um is determined to um
pursue the agenda of the of the jackson
administration which is to make sure
that the slave order is safe in
washington that the slave owners are
safe with their property that they're
they're not going to be their slaves are
not going to run away
and so he
as district attorney has the job of
establishing law and order and so he he
does this
in a couple of ways
the first thing that he does is he puts
arthur bowen on trial for the attempted
murder of mrs thornton he also arrests
um and puts on trial a a white
abolitionist an anti-slavery man from
new york a doctor named reuben crandall
who had been bringing
a trunk load of anti-slavery
publications to washington and key
wanted to send the message
to to not just to the anti-slavery
forces in washington but to the
anti-slavery forces everywhere in the
country your activities will not be
tolerated at all and so um that the book
tells the story of how the riot comes to
pass and then the story of the criminal
trials that follow
so
when arthur bowen goes on trial in
december of 1835 key is very eager to
win a
a conviction
by this time mrs thornton has come
forward and and come to the defense
of her alleged assailant and she says in
the trial
that um arthur never lifted the acts
that she never believed that he intended
to hurt her that she felt safe in his
presence
that he was just drunk and that
she she wanted the whole thing to go
away well he was implacable and he
didn't listen to this he managed to get
other people to override her testimony
and so arthur bowen is convicted and
there's only one punishment for that
which is the death penalty capital
punishment
and so
arthur bowen uh
goes on to death row
and in january of 1836
is sentenced to die in about a month
and so with the clock ticking
mrs thornton um does something even more
unbelievable i mean it was it was
amazing enough that she had testified on
arthur's behalf
in in the criminal trial but now she
goes out and starts recruiting her
friends
in high society of washington and she
was a very prominent woman with many
prominent friends
easy access to
the leadership of the country she went
to vice president van buren and said you
know use your good offices with the
president with president jackson tell
him that he should pardon arthur um
uh you know his mother is very good um
you know that uh she says uh you know
the
the execution would be worse than the
crime
and that she couldn't contemplate that
arthur would be executed
he and jackson are uh unmoved um and so
the clock keeps ticking
down
and i'm going to read you a little part
of the book about
what happens in february of 1836.
in his cell arthur bowen searched for a
way to quell the fear of death
he hoped for a pardon from the president
but he had to be ready if it did not
happen
he had to admit the truth of what john
cook had said all along yes he had a
right to be free and yes liquor would
destroy that freedom
arthur's protestations that he never
intended to harm mrs thornton no longer
failed to convince even himself of
course he had no intention the drink
gave him that intention unleashed the
sinner within
by drinking the sudden passion of the
murderer is sharpened john cook had in
tone john cook was a school teacher who
kind of advised arthur about
ways to get his freedom but he was also
a a temperance man and he always told
the young slave boys if you wanted to be
if you wanted to be free you had to do
two things you had to learn to read and
write and you had to stop drinking
arthur had condemned himself and for
that he had to take responsibility he
decided to write a poem about this
feeling of repentance
with pen and paper in hand he sat in the
dim light of his jail cell thinking
about his friends from the racetrack and
president square
like william thornton he had a talent
for some talent for writing
farewell farewell my young friends dear
oh view my dreadful state each flying
moment brings me near unto my awful fate
he made a curious reference to his
family brought up i was by parents nice
whose commands i would not obey but
plunged ahead foremost into vice and
into temptations dreadful way
he admitted his folly in scoring the
teachings of his elders
nothing did i ever drink but liquor very
strong alas i never used to think that i
was doing wrong
to me was read the awful sentence oh
dreadful in my ears it rang they gave me
time for my repentance and then i must
be hanged
goodbye goodbye my friends so dear may
god almighty please you all do if you
please shed butt a tear at arthur
bowen's unhappy fall
copies of arthur's poem soon circulated
the intelligencer which was the big
newspaper in washington published a copy
the editor of the metropolitan which was
the newspaper in georgetown pronounced
it very credible everyone in washington
seemed to know that mrs thornton's
personal petition for clemency to arthur
had been presented to president jackson
it asked him to exercise that mercy
which is in his power alone
the people awaited jackson's response
said the georgetown metropolitan with
the deepest anxiety
i'm going to leave it there
you have to buy the book find out
what happens next
um
so i want to close with with with one
note um uh just to bring this story back
to the present um in the uh when the
book was reviewed in the washington post
the um
uh the uh the reviewer took issue with
an argument that i make in in the book
which is that as i spent more and more
time writing the book i realized that
there was more and more similarity
between the politics of the 1830s and
our politics today and i said that
really
the the the the red blue politics that
we that we
that we see today the red states
conservative the blue states liberal if
you if you look it really originates in
this period and
and uh i disagree quite strongly with
that with that with the reviewers
contention
he said readers may find the element of
the book jarring beginning with the
assertion that pro-slavery and
anti-slavery forces in the 1830s
resembled today's political division
between red conservative and blue
liberal this anachronism is unhelpful at
best misleading at worst um i i i
totally disagree i think i think that
the the similarities are are quite clear
and as i point out in the book they
really revolve around the timeless
issues of american politics and it's no
surprise that they are that they are the
same uh then as now um
uh americans argue about
what are property rights how you know
what what kind of property rights does
any individual have
in the 1830s that that argument revolved
around slavery did people have the right
to own property in people and the the
red forces which are traditionally the
force that are in favor of more property
rights maximal property rights we're in
favor of the maximal property rights
embodied in slavery and the liberal
forces which are traditionally
have a more restricted view of property
rights uh had you know said no there's
no such thing as property in people um
likewise in the debate uh debates about
citizenship uh part of the debate about
slavery was a debate about citizenship
did the blacks have the right to be
citizens it's very similar to today's
debate about illegal immigration do
these people have the right to be do
they deserve the rights to be citizen
then as now the conservatives took the
restrictive position no
uh american citizenship is reserved for
a smaller group for native born
americans
then as now the liberals took a more
expansive view
that citizenship was open to a greater
number of people
also with free speech when when francis
scott key is prosecuting the
anti-slavery movement it's it's a
classic free speech argument of the type
we still have today
he said no we have to restrict free
speech rights for to protect our safety
you know if we if we allow the
anti-slavery forces to say this then
we'll have slave rebellions and we'll
all be insecure so we need to
restrict free speech rights and that's
the same argument that conservatives
make today and liberals make
likewise make the same take the same
position then as they do now which is no
free speech rights should be maximal and
we should we should worry less about
safety and more about preserving free
speech rights so that is a very strong
theme that runs throughout the book um
and some people disagree with it
read for yourself and uh and decide for
yourself so with that i think i'm going
to stop and maybe just answer some any
questions that people have about the
book or whatever what i've said so far
yes
where did you first
come across this piece of history and
how long
did you nurture it before you decided to
write a book
um
i first heard about this in about 1998 i
was a reporter at the washington post i
was working on a story about a
neighborhood
historic preservation dispute which got
me to read some history of the city of
washington and that's where i found i
first heard that there had been a race
riot in 1835 and i heard that francis
scott key had been the district attorney
and i thought that was really
interesting and i went around the post
newsroom and i asked people
have you did you ever know about this
race riot has anybody ever written about
this and nobody had written about it and
nobody knew about it so i knew it was a
story then
um and so uh i wrote a piece for the
sunday magazine for the washington post
in 2005. but i always thought it was
such a great story that if i ever had
the chance i would write a whole book
about it and so i kind of had it in the
back of my mind and then in 2009 i got
fired from a job and i said
no job you always want to write that
book go write that book and have a good
time so i had been nurturing it all
along and so even after i wrote the
article in 2005 i always thought i will
write a book about this someday so and i
had continued to read in the period and
do more research so i nurtured it for a
long time then when i got the contract
that was three years ago so it took
about two
two years to research and finish the
book in that whole time
so
you mentioned uh william lloyd garrison
basically being tutored by
lundy i believe yes and and what
he was alive at this particular
incident was he in washington do you say
well um so garrison what garrison and
lundy did that nobody had ever done in
american journalism before was they
would go out and write about specific
slave traders and they would name names
nobody had ever done this before lundy
started doing it and he taught garrison
how to do it and so
um
originally they were publishing in in
baltimore which was a bigger slave
trading town and so they both wrote
articles about different slave traders
um
one saying uh this man was a beast
because he had sold off children he had
broken up families um actually both of
them that's what they they wrote about
and in both cases the slave traders
waylaid them after their articles
appeared
beat the hell out of them um and then
when when lundy filed charges in his
case the judge said well you deserved it
and dismissed the charges and dismissed
the case in the garrison's case uh the
after after beating garrison up the
slave trader also charged him with libel
and um
so garrison was about to go on trial in
uh in baltimore in 1833 and was
knew that he was not going to get a fair
trial and so he skipped town and so he
left in 1833 and he he went back to
boston and that's when he founded the
liberator which became the great
anti-slavery publication united states
so and lundy had to leave town as well
he charged him in 1833 with
uh
londy wrote an article uh about a story
that was well known in washington at the
time which was a black woman was walking
across the bridge over the potomac
and a constable started chasing her
and people all the black people in
washington knew what that meant the
constables supplemented their income by
kidnapping free blacks and selling them
into slavery
and so the woman ran away because she
knew they were trying to to kidnap her
and she fell off the bridge she fell in
the potomac she drowned
they got her body out and buried her and
that was that nobody did anything and so
lundy wrote an article and he said look
here's what happened here's the name of
the constable and if the district
attorney isn't going to do something
about it then congress should do
something about it
and so
he hit the roof he was furious and so he
immediately charged lundy with libel and
uh and went on charged him and his
printer another white man who had helped
him run off the copies because they were
really he was really trying to drive the
anti-slavery people out of the capitol
they wanted to get rid of the
anti-slavery forces in washington
and so um
and so lundy did the same thing as
garrison he was facing like a thousand
dollar fine which would be like
you know
twenty thousand dollars or you know a
hundred thousand dollars in today's
money and so
um
lundy collected one last meal from his
friends and he took off and went and
went to philadelphia so
um yeah so the the anti-slavery movement
was very embattled uh throughout this
time and that was you know that was
key's mission was to
kind of drive these people out and and
suppress them
so
sure
was there uh
at this time what you would call
mainstream press that was
covering the this whole thing including
uh the evolution abolitionist newspapers
and
no um
there were a lot of papers at the time
there were three daily newspapers in
washington at the time
reflecting three different political
tendencies and there was a weekly
newspaper and then there was a weekly
newspaper in georgetown which was a
separate you know georgetown is now part
of washington dc but then it was a
separate municipality so there were a
lot of newspapers but these were
newspapers that were aligned with
political factions in the government and
so
they would talk about they would write
about slavery as the politics of slavery
were playing out in congress somebody
presented a petition for the abolition
of slavery in the district of columbia
they would write a story about that but
about the experience of slavery or the
abuses of slavery they would never
they would never write it up and what
about the race riot
and
the oh the
trial and the
the the ritz and all that the race riot
was was very well covered because it was
it was very shocking and nobody expected
that to happen and there was a lot of
recriminations and debate and you know
and who was responsible kind of then the
white working men
the riot was attributed in the
newspapers to what were called mechanics
and a mechanic was
a mechanic was a was any kind of working
man it wasn't like our our you know our
conception of an auto mechanic it was
any manual worker
well the
mechanics got together at least some of
them and said you know how dare you say
that you know we did this you know we we
didn't do that so there were there were
lots of recriminations and that was
covered in the uh uh and and
uh
but you know like what happened to
beverly snow nobody ever wrote about
that but you could tell when i in
reading the newspapers i saw i mean
snoke took out advertisements all the
time that was one that was the chief way
that i figured out who he was
because he
his his ads were very witty they changed
all the time
and he really disclosed a lot of his
personality in there but you know when
push came to shove
nobody no white authorities wanted to be
seen in the position of defending the
free blacks and so that was why that was
why the public authority kind of
collapsed because nobody wanted to to be
seen as doing that and the newspapers
were part of that
you know
they really didn't want to they didn't
want to touch the issue it was a little
too explosive for them
and mrs thornton's campaign
mrs thornton's campaign
well that was the thing was they
couldn't avoid they couldn't ignore mrs
thornton mrs thornton was very prominent
her husband william thornton had
designed the u.s capital was a very
close friend of george washington was a
close friend of thomas jefferson so she
was a leading lady in society
and so
while they wouldn't write about what she
was doing directly i mean in that part
you know you could tell the new the word
had gotten around that mrs thornton was
trying to get was trying to help arthur
and so that was kind of you could kind
of see that nobody ever wrote an article
about that but
you heard intimations of that throughout
the press coverage of the time
so
yeah
um a couple questions
you you um have talked a lot about the
different parallels um between then and
now
and you've i guess i'd be interested
just more frontally talking about race
than and now um and what what parallels
you might see and then
also
um
you're
i'm talking about the then and now
you're it's kind of something like we're
condemned to repeat history is that your
is that your conclusion or is there
something we can learn from
what you're i mean right no i mean the
the i i think the yes the politics of
race are central and and and when i talk
about those principles you know that
that we debate in kind of red blue
liberal conservative division um you
know race runs through those and
that's a big part of it i mean i think
one thing that's remarkable about this
story and i remember on inauguration day
when president obama is coming up
pennsylvania avenue and he gets out and
he starts walking down the street and
i'm watching a tv and i'm like oh my god
that's snow's corner you know that was
where beverly snow had his restaurant
and i realized and nobody knows it not
even barack obama himself who's like
this is like a quintessential obama
story and nobody knows it and i think to
me
i don't know if this is not doesn't
directly answer your question but this
idea of you know just
black success is just like written out
of history it's just it's it's sort of
religiously forgotten and i mean that's
the only way that's my only explanation
for why this story has been is not known
why nobody knows the story of beverly
snow or the or or the riot of 1835
um are we condemned to repeat it well i
mean i think that i think the obama
experience tells you that you know these
continuities run very deep you know and
uh uh the backlash against obama i think
is very akin to the backlash against
beverly snow
uh i don't see any other way to look at
i mean obama's the president he's not
running a restaurant so you know i think
yeah the country's in in better shape
but the underlying dynamics are still
there they haven't changed that much
so
this might be kind of beyond the scope
of the book but um was there any uh sort
of
organized or uh vocalized um
response
uh
from the black community itself in
washington city at the time
uh was it basically everybody running
and hiding
uh no there there was in fact isaac
carey who was the barber he was a
probably beverly snow's best friend and
had a barber shop right next to the
restaurant
then
filed a lawsuit
because there was a crackdown on black
businesses after all this happened
perversely the white authorities
the response to the white riot was to
crack down on black business and to deny
blacks the right to own licenses to
in his case he was selling perfume in
his barbershop and he wanted to keep his
license to sell perfume um and he won
that case um
but uh the riot was very discouraging
for washington and um a lot of the a lot
of the the the most able and successful
blacks left and went to went to toronto
and beverly snow and william walker who
was his business partner and other free
black men wound up in toronto the kerry
brothers thomas and isaac carey wound up
in toronto so it was kind of an exodus
because
they had really reached the limits of
what was possible in washington and uh
they had seen that they weren't gonna be
able they weren't gonna be allowed to go
any farther and so uh they moved on
yeah say something about the research
your frustrations your triumphs
well um uh
i always knew like your question that i
was gonna do this book and one reason
why i knew it was because the sources
were so
interesting and there were so many good
sources
probably the first or first and foremost
was the
anna thornton uh by the time this story
takes place is 55 years old she has been
keeping a diary of her life for close to
40 years
and pretty much wrote down
every day
you know five days a week six days a
week
what happened in her life she wasn't
this is not an emotional diary she was
not a confessional or expressive type of
person but she just said what happened
in her life you know mr adams came over
that was john quincy adams the former
president mr adams came over we played
chess you know i read um
she read
mary shelley frankenstein and she
thought that was very morbid um
she went to the market and she paid you
know 12 cents for a dozen eggs and she
wrote she she wrote down everything that
she
all of her purchases so for recreating
daily life this was an extraordinary
source and it made me realize that i was
going to be able to
recreate daily life in a very intimate
realistic way so that i didn't want to
write a book about congress and
politicians i want to write a book about
the way people lived in washington
and this became a kind of mission of
mine as i got into this research was to
write a book that was about really about
living in washington and not about
washington politics um
the the daily newspapers were an
abundant source of information just
because there were so many of them
and you had these different tendencies
so they would look at things
slightly differently you know
and you could get a lot of information
that way
and then i spent a lot of time in the
national archives and i found the docket
book of the court
for the circuit court at the time so you
could find out you know who was breaking
the law and how they were breaking the
law who was suing each other how did
business deals go bad
you could really get a real sense of the
texture of daily life
and then finally the last thing was the
um
the property tax records which were also
in these big bound volumes um and there
i could track you know i could see
beverly snow getting richer by the year
you know when he comes to town he has
nothing after a first year he's got a
hundred dollars at the second year he's
got 200 third year he's got 300 so you
know three if you're making 300 a year
at that time you're starting to move
into the middle class
so you could file you could track
characters that way so
that was another way that i really you
know learned a lot about
the characters that are in this book
and then there was then there was
francis scott key himself who
is
you know everybody knows his name and
yet there hadn't been a biography of him
written since 1939
um and so there was a lot about francis
scott key that was just lying around and
roger tawny and when i was doing this
research i mean i found in the in the
court records many indictments
you know hand signed fs key i mean i had
in my hands i had 100 autographs of
francis scott key
so
that was a you know that was a uh a
thing
the
but the thing that i'm i think i'm most
proud of is figuring out who beverly
snow was through his advertisements um
because
he left no records he left no diary or
letters
wherever he went he seemed to attract
attention because there were always
people always had anecdotes about him
but i really didn't know that much about
him until
and i'd seen some of the ads and i
thought that was interesting then i
realized no you need to go back and you
need to read every single newspaper and
get every single ad because that's going
to be where he expressed himself and in
fact they're very funny and and you
really get a sense of the man one one of
his favorite ads was called health made
cheap
and he was selling the idea of health
food in 1830s it was like this food is
not only good it's good for you you know
a very modern idea i mean beverly snow
was a great
in the true washington tradition he was
a master of self-promotion you know he
was he was great at it a self-invented
american and i think that's really the
thing that i i like the most about this
book is that this person who nobody knew
existed actually comes to life and you
realize what a great and unusual person
he was
and there he is on the pages of the book
did you compile a book all at once
absorb all the information and then
compile the book or did you start to
compile the book as you went and then
revise it
well i mean if you're overwhelmed at
times with all this reading then with
information or did you pace yourself
yeah well i i did it in phases i'd
written the article the magazine article
so i had i had expressed it but when i
started to write the book i decided i
would not write start writing right away
and i spent about nine months just doing
research
and then just the idea was just get
everything in place and don't try and
start too early
then once i had that in place um
uh i wasn't overwhelmed um
i mean it took a while i i there were
three drafts of this book three full
different versions of it so it took a
while to kind of get it under control
and figure out what was most important
and what could be cut out and one
version was like 700 pages long
and that was later you know by the end
it was probably
300 manuscript pages long so a lot got
left out which you're very lucky because
it wasn't that interesting
um
so but yeah i mean it it took a while to
get the material under control for sure
did you use a filing system or did you
use that geological stratification
system that your father used
what i did was i made a file uh and i
had a separate file folder
for the key period of the of the book
which is 1835 and 1836 where i had a
folder for every day of the year
and every newspaper article i would put
it into i would put it into that and so
then when the time came and i was
writing about august 1835 i could just
pull out a week and i would have all the
newspaper articles all of my notes in a
row
and you know ready to tell the story
like that i have a horror of a blank
page as a writer you never want to sit
down and look at a blank page because
then you go oh my god it's like you
don't know where to begin you don't know
what to do so what you always want to do
is you always want to have good notes in
front of you and so really what you're
doing is just kind of
editing the notes and turning the notes
into pros so you're never looking at a
blank page and that's what that's how i
could get going on it
yeah so did you do this by heart copy or
on your computer
uh
a little bit of both i mean um i like
having i like having paper copies um
when i started i and was reading the
newspapers at the library of congress
you could only make photocopies of them
later on they had this very cool machine
where you could
make pdfs right off the newspaper
but so i had to at some points i had to
so i kind of had a parallel
two parallel systems it was kind of
inefficient but
it was just that was that was the only
way to to do it and then there were you
know things that um i had found in
you know letters and things like that
that i would make copies of it but never
turn them into things to go under the
computer so
i'm i'm i'm half in the digital world
but still half in the paper world
make it happen
yeah i'm interested in the uh the
texture the change of the city of
washington you mentioned 1835 30 000
people right 12 000 are african-american
right of the 12 000 how many are free
uh
six thousand plus as a majority by like
you know 50. so there's an exodus after
this event
what changes within washington well no
actually that trend continues and the
free black population in washington
continues to grow and in fact by the by
the beginning of the civil war free
black people outnumber slaves in
washington like four to one
so in the next 20 years
because
you have to understand that um if you
were a black person in virginia and you
got your freedom you had to leave the
state within a year by law or you could
be sold back into slavery and so those
people once they got there
they weren't going to go to boston or
new york even though there was no
slavery in those places but i mean first
of all you know philadelphia was a four
or five day ride
uh
at best and then it's an alien culture
it's not a southern culture so
uh the blacks once they got their
freedom they went to the district and
they flocked to the district and there
were jobs there there was opportunity
there slavery was legal there but
you know the the system of slavery in
washington again this was a big surprise
to me you know this was not plantation
slavery um mrs thornton uh mrs thornton
had a a guy who a servant who she owned
a man named george plant and he was her
driver and he was kind of the jack of
all trades who kept the house up and
fixed the wagons and did all of that
well george george plant had a a wife
who was free and she lived in georgetown
and he had four kids and they were free
and he would go home at night and so and
then in the morning he go so he was a
slave who commuted
but that was i mean that was one of the
one of the variations of slavery in
washington at that time also a lot of
slaves made money by their owners would
hire them out so
your owner would say okay
you'd be hired out to the owner of a
hotel you'd go you'd be a waiter in the
hotel
the owner of the hotel would pay your
owner your wages and so but you were
there you were a waiter you could make
tips you controlled your own time so
slavery was a much more fluid thing in
washington and that's one reason why the
anti-slavery movement could get going
was because there was more room to
operate and this was one of the things
that
that key was most upset about was that
this freedom
these little corners of freedom that the
blacks were finding
everybody understood that was going to
be the toehold that was going to be the
foot in the door to greater freedom and
that was what they were out you know
that was what they were trying to
repress and so like i said this is when
the real ideological struggle over
slavery begins when the slave power is
determined to stamp out the anti-slavery
forces and the anti-slavery forces are
beginning to organize themselves appeal
to public opinion gain strength in the
congress and that's the fight that you
know grinds on and then eventually
culminates in the civil war 25 years
later
so
to build on that then you're uh your
commuter slave for lack of a better term
would that be more like a like an
indentured slave with someone coming uh
owing money would they be able to
uh buy their freedom at that point in
time
no um uh i got some earning potential no
that would that would still be up to the
to the owner
um there were uh
but there were conditions like that like
beverly snow
for i have never quite figured this out
but he had a term sort of written into
his terms of slavery that he would be
free when he was 30.
and so when he was 30 he bought his
freedom for five dollars but that was
something that was had been recognized
that he was due and that was legally his
due there were white indentured servants
although that was dying out by the 1830s
um
but you know how how black people got
their freedom it happened all different
ways sometimes you know
it was given to you sometimes when
people died they freed all their slaves
sometimes they said you know
the slaves would have to pay you know
the going rate like you know for a
healthy young person that could be
eight hundred dollars a thousand dollars
you know which was a lot a lot of money
i mean you could live for a couple of
years on a thousand dollars
um so but
slavery was there were there were there
were lots of permutations of slavery in
washington lots of race mixing too i
mean
it's amazing to think about but
there's no doubt about it washington was
a more racially integrated city in 1835
than it is in 2012.
there were no black neighborhoods in in
washington in in in in in 2000 in 1835
blacks and whites lived very much
intermingled there were you know black
blocks and things like that but there
was no
oh that's a black neighborhood that that
did not exist at that time
do you know the degree of black literacy
at this time
it's very hard to tell um john cook was
a a free black man um and he was the
like the smartest black guy in town
everybody agreed and he was the teacher
at the school and he had organized a
little group for young black men which
arthur bowen was part of
which was trying to teach them okay you
want to get out of slavery here's how
you do it so um and he you know
he had a school and there was a william
wormley who was the son of lynch wormley
who owned delivery stable also had a
school so
you know there was there was education
but you know like what percentage
i don't know i mean arthur bowen was was
was very well was obviously literate if
he could have written that poem um
mrs thornton's uh had taught him to read
and write
but how common that was i don't you know
i don't really know it's very hard to
say but if it would
it was not unknown that black people
were you know were literate
even slaves
okay
anybody else
sure
who was mrs thornton in bed alone or who
was she with
[Laughter]
mrs thornton so her husband had died um
so she lived in her house with her own
mother who had been a school teacher uh
and who was very fond of arthur as well
in fact i think
mrs thornton's mother was probably the
one who taught arthur how to read and
write
so in in her bedroom that night was mrs
thornton her mother and then maria bowen
was was anna thornton's personal servant
and she also slept in the same room as
the two other women
so and i don't you know like i don't
know if that was unusual i do know you
can tell from the diary that anna
thornton and maria bowen were
you know were very close i mean they ran
that household together and you know
they had fights and you know all of that
but they were they were very dependent
on each other you know and so
uh
they slept in the same bedroom that's i
mean that's all i know okay but she and
she's the one of course that's only one
that stood up and
yeah okay yeah yeah
will you tell us if uh mrs thornton
recorded in her diary the day after
arthur came in with the axe
last night arthur came in with the axe
or should we no as as her as her as her
drive to save arthur
to to get art to save arthur on death
row as it accelerates
it all comes down to what president
jackson thinks and so she has to
convince him and so she writes an
18-page letter 18-page handwritten
letter in which she describes
the whole event in
i mean second by second detail both
everything that led up to it and
everything that that followed so yeah
you get a very
you learn firsthand exactly what what
she saw and what had happened that night
and you had access to that letter yeah i
found that letter in the in the the the
pardon papers of the president all
pardon
requests for pardons petitions to the
president go into a file
and uh in the in the petition file i
found anna thornton's letter
uh for the appealing for the for the
pardon of arthur bowen
so yeah and
the original
handwritten
doesn't that raise for you
how many other fascinating stories are
just
sitting here underneath another piece of
paper
i mean after writing this book many many
i mean if
i'm sure they're there i'm sure they're
there and and i think they're they could
be very unexpected and surprising
so i'm still looking for it so i can
write another book
[Music]
okay would that be one of the main
lessons that you got from writing this
book or was there another one that you
could tell us about
uh that was i mean that was really the
big one was that that you know the
the way history is taught it can be so
can be so misleading you know and that
the way
the key is to get to the reality of how
people lived you know not the politics
the way history is traditionally
construed but actually you know what was
the day-to-day life of the people like
that's the that's what i came away with
so okay well thank you
[Applause]
for more information visit jefferson